notre action en ce mois d'octobre est de
sensibiliser la population sur la
prévention la pratique d'activités
physiques et pratique sportive et si
vous cela qu'il y aura dans ce relais
pour la vie
21 et 22 octobre il ya aussi plusieurs
défis alors nos relations sur ceux qui
participent à ce mois d'octobre avec un
défi au niveau de la natation nous avons
un tout jeune qui va faire un défi
considérable entre choisi les efforts de
france il fera sa le 15 octobre mais
nous avons aussi au lamentin dans cette
piscine du lamentin de la ville du
lamentin une manifestation le bonnet
rose donc l'occasion pour tout le monde
de revenir ici
nager faire de l'activité physique et en
même temps soutenir les actions de la
ligue contre le cancer je rappelle que
des études des éditions passées ont
permis déjà d'avoir un montant
considérable l'an dernier 600 mille
euros pour notre opération de ap 06 la
structure qui va pouvoir héberger qui va
pas qu'il va pouvoir permettre aux
antilles nick est de faire de l'activité
physique d'avoir un accompagnement de
tous ceux qui sont concernés par la
maladie du début à la fin ce mois
d'octobre nous permet nous permettre de
faire de désintensifier elle
d'épissage dépistage du cancer du sein
mais nous avons remarqué que lorsque
nous médiatisant un dépistage que ce
soit le col de l'utérus
le cancer du sein rouleau colorectal
mais si nous le faisons pour le st les
autres points quand ces cancers sont
anciennes et donc c'est une façon pour
nous de lancer des campagnes de
dépistage pour augmenter le taux de
participation aux différents dépistages
parce que lorsqu'on arrivera à dépister
des cancers précoces ils sont mieux
prises en charge et nous pour voir
athènes valablement une guérison
je rappelle qu'on guérit plus de 50% des
gens plus de 50 % des cancers et donc
c'est ces gens courageux la population à
participer à ces campagnes de dépistage